[Applaudissements]
en 2015
j'ai fait des rencontres incroyables et
elle m'en a mené jusqu ici devant vous
accompagné de mes amis
hassan et moulins en fait je vais ici
pour vous dire à quel point aller à la
rencontre de l'autre ça peut être
quelque chose d'extraordinaire et vous
allez être embarqué dans une aventure
humaine sans précédent et tout ça je
vous assure c'est que du bonheur alors
oui moi je suis allé à la rencontre de
l'autre et je vous invite aussi à faire
de même parce que c'est peut-être des
personnes qui vous font peur des
personnes beaucoup plus âgés ou beaucoup
plus jeunes aux cultures sûrement très
différentes des vôtres et qui pourtant
peuvent changer votre vie ce que ça a
été le cas pour moi donc je me suis dit
pourquoi pas vous aussi
alors moi en 2015 j'ai choisi d'aller
vers une population très médiatisée il
s'agit des réfugiés et pour ça je vous
le dis tout de suite je n'ai pas
intégrer de grandes associations
je n'ai pas non plus passer tout mon
temps à aider ces personnes et je ne
suis pas non plus devenu la nouvelle
mère teresa en fait j'ai juste aidé par
des actions concrètes des personnes pour
qui tout était compliqué mon objectif
était simple c'était de permettre à des
personnes nouvellement arrivés en france
de se sentir bien chez nous et pour ça
vraiment c'était des gestes très simples
à la portée de tous
quand par exemple juste prendre mon
temps pour permettre à une personne
étrangère de parler français et
d'entendre français c'est simple j'ai
aussi passé des coups de fil pour
prendre des rendez vous médicaux ou
encore j'ai envoyé quelques mails pour
permettre un ex basketteur semi
professionnel en syrie de poursuivre ici
sa passion
voyez alors si moi j'ai pu le faire je
vous assure vous aussi vous pouvez le
faire
si en 2015 et choisi d'aider des
réfugiés c'est parce que j'ai vu cette
photo que vous connaissez tous des tout
c'est une photo qui m'a beaucoup ému et
qui m'a choqué aussi c'est la photo du
petit dylan c'est un enfant c'est rien
de 5 ans qui a fui la guerre en syrie
avec sa famille et qui malheureusement
il n'y a pas survécu
et là quand j'ai vu ça je me suis dit
qu'il fallait y aller je me suis dit que
vraiment il était temps de passer à
l'action qui valaient vraiment agir
alors je savais bien que je pouvais pas
agir malheureusement pour aider ceux qui
sont restés en syrie ni pour aider ceux
qui traversent la méditerranée tous les
jours pour venir jusque chez nous mais
en revanche là où j'ai dû pouvoir d'agir
et là où vous aussi vous avez du pouvoir
d'agir
c'est pour aider celles et ceux qui sont
arrivés jusque chez nous ici en france
et qui galèrent alors puisqu'ils sont
ici je vais les laisser prendre la
parole et vous raconter leur quotidien
depuis un an seulement en france ils
vont vous raconter leurs envies et leurs
difficultés mourlam et résonne
en fait ça semble tout est compliqué
imaginez vous vous démarquez retirer et
vous pouvez vous installer trouver un
logement régulariser votre situation et
vous faire des amis en commun
mais problème vous ne parlait pas arabe
les angles de matelas alors avis à un
conflit trop sur le bel20 collabora
voilà c'est exactement ce que si vous
savez que moi en france
quand je suis arrivé ici je ne savais
rien je ne comprenais rien et surtout
personne ne me comprenait vous avez
vraiment des mots compliqués qui je
n'aurais voix à dire par exemple moi
j'habite à paris
mais audi vous je n'arrive même pas à
bronze élément paraît correctement parce
que dans ma langue leçon paix existe pas
donc vous imaginez à quel point tout
petit coup de gueule encore
association à bord dont j'ai encore de
l'avenir
association ouais et qui sont souvent
les associations nous aide et nous
disent qu'elle peut bien on doit donner
à l'administration est dévolu pour moi
il y en a beaucoup
sens d'associations oui son association
ba ba de statut de réfugié donc quand un
demain à prononcer des mots basiques on
est on a l'impression qu'on en fasse des
obstacles insurmontables
et en plus de ça en plus de mes
difficultés linguistiques pour prononcé
de son super compliqué pour moi j'étais
complètement de couvrir et m'adapter à
une nouvelle culture une nouvelle valeur
par exemple la bise la première fois
qu'on personnes m'appellent avize
j'avais vraiment l'impression qu'il
voulait m'embrasser sur la bouche grasse
français et françaises qui m'ont aidé
dans mon quotidien je peux apprendre
naturellement les règles de votre
société qui sont naturels pour vous mais
qui sont tellement nouvelle pour moi en
fait je pense sincèrement colette que
des personnes qui m'ont apporté ici m'a
vraiment permis de m'intégrer et de
vivre par la française parce que comment
aurais-je dû adapter mon comportement
vous habite août si aucun français
n'avait faire l'effort de venir vers moi
et de m'expliquer ce que je peux faire
ce que je veux dire en société parce
qu'il ne faut pas croire quand je suis
arrivé ici j'avais vraiment mort je me
sentais seul et impuissant
j'étais comme un enfant qui devait tout
réapprendre
mais le fait de rester avec 2 français 2
m'a permis de me rassurer sur la
situation
en bref de me sentir accompagné de ma
nouvelle vie en fréquentant en
fréquentant nos français en imitant
votre façon de vivre
j'ai pas prendre naturellement est
vraiment facilement vos règles vous avez
tout et les adapter
s'adapter à ce que tu as toujours connu
c'est toujours à ce que j'ai toujours
connu
et ça ça se fait sans douleur sans trop
de difficultés franchement parfois avec
des malentendus et parfois souvent
pardon avec beaucoup d'humour par
exemple quand on trinque on doit se
regarder dans les yeux et franchement
c'est pas pourquoi et
maintenant ça y est je suis habitué mais
j'ai pris aussi un autre exemple
confirme a posé un lapin ça n'a rien à
voir avec le petit animal c'est juste
qu'on ne vient pas à mon rendez vous
voilà c'est donc grâce à vous grâce aux
personnes qui m'ont aidée j'ai bougé
pour prendre confiance en moi et
commencé à construire ma nouvelle vie en
fait j'ai vraiment l'impression d'avoir
intégré un nouveau nouvelle grande
famille et ça ça n'aurait pas été
possible si je fais tu es tout seul oui
l air d elia blanc des versions qui se
mobilise au quotidien pour les autres et
même si on ne voit pas dans l'immédiat
elles sont bien là oui on peut tous se
mobiliser chacun à notre manière
selon nos moyens et nos disponibilités
pour aider quelqu'un qui en a vraiment
besoin
une ou deux heures par semaine c'est
vraiment rien alors je sais ce que vous
allez me dire vous allez me dire que
vous avez beaucoup de travail que vous
avez une famille mais quand on y
réfléchit on sait que 1 français reste
en moyenne quatre heures par jour devant
la télévision
alors moi ce que je vous propose c'est
de troquer ses quatre heures par jour
devant la télévision par deux heures par
semaine pour aider une personne qui en a
besoin parce qu'encore une fois dans la
rencontre de l'autre il peut se passer
vraiment des choses géniales que vous
n'aurez pourrait pas connaître
si vous n'osez pas dépasser votre peur
et si vous n'osez pas aller à la
rencontre de l'autre
alors allez-y faites le premier pas
[Applaudissements]
j'ai pas envie de j'ai pas envie de
rester
j'avais envie comme on regarde comment
un beau petit refuge dans ma vie j'ai
pas envie de rester un réfugié aux états
français dans ma vie parce que oui j'ai
choisi la france comme un nouveau billet
j'ai envie de jouer envie d'être
remboursés comme vous tous et toutes que
tu veux dire ce que tu veux dire je
pense c'est que les réfugiés ce sont
avant tout des hommes des femmes et des
enfants qui ont été obligés de partir de
leur pays et qui aujourd'hui n'aspire
qu'à retrouver une vie normale sans que
nous les accueillons nous ayons pitié
d'eux oui ça j'ai envie d'être un brin d
environ c'est quand vous j'ai envie
qu'on remarque en commun gens qui
partagent les mêmes difficultés et la
meuse movie la manne de zombies dos les
deux jours du mot nage ici en france
j'ai envie aussi de sortir grandie de
cette aventure qui m'a amené jusqu'ici
parce que je le pense je pense qu'il n'y
a rien de mieux que pouvoir mélanger
entre bill entre plusieurs cultures et
valeurs franchement je recherchais y
avait uniquement comme en syrie ni
totalement comme en français je cherche
ce juste milieu pour pouvoir
[Musique]
ce jeu c'était millions est bientôt là
pour pouvoir mélanger plusieurs cultures
et mourir ce chemin socialement entre
les deux cultures pour pour pouvoir être
personnes le talent et rentrent plus
ouverte aux personnes mayer et grâce à
ça aujourd'hui j'ai la chance d'être
bilingue être bilingue en français donc
il ne tient qu'à nous tous d'amorcer ce
cercle vertueux de solidarité et de
générosité
et ça ça ne peut que contribuer à rendre
nos sociétés meilleurs
alors bien sûr vous n'êtes pas obligé
d'avoir le même idéal que moi à savoir
aider les réfugiés surtout s'il n'y en a
pas autour de vous mais je suis sûr que
partout autour de vous il ya des
personnes qui ont besoin d aide qu'il
s'agisse d'étrangers de personnes âgées
isolées ou encore d'adolescents en quête
d'identité
bref vous assure on a vraiment vraiment
de quoi faire
et encore une fois pas besoin d'être un
grand nombre de personne ni de passer un
grand nombre de temps pour aider ces
personnes seulement une ou deux
personnes suffisent parce que ce coup de
pouce que vous allez leur apporter ça
peut changer beaucoup beaucoup de choses
pour elle en fait vous pouvez être leur
héros du quotidien et c'est ça que je
vous propose d'expérimenter à vous seul
vous pouvez contribuer à retrouver du
lien social et à vraiment découvrir ce
que vivre ensemble veut dire moi cette
aide
elle m'a amené ici avec mes amis ghoulam
et hassan et d'ailleurs avant de partir
on a une dernière chose à vous dire
aider les personnes autour de vous vous
en ressortirez horrifie montmagny à
l'action
[Applaudissements]